we start today with another chaos
element in fact thrown into the 2024
Republican primary race the mayor of
Miami Francis Suarez a republican
announced this morning that he is
running for president he's challenging
of course Donald Trump the presumptive
front-runner in that 2024 Republican
race but also Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis Suarez if we say that Trump is
a Floridian now which I guess he is you
know he famously changed his residency
to Florida a Suarez becomes the third
current or former Florida elected
official Floridian elected official I
think better said to enter the race and
this is going to be interesting for a
couple of different reasons one is that
Suarez is Hispanic and there is
increasingly a focus on Hispanic voters
the right talking about hispanic voters
as sort of like don't assume that
they're just going to vote for Democrats
which is true
as I talked about before although
Hispanic voters lean left significantly
not quite as much as black Americans and
Jewish Americans but Hispanic Americans
do lean left Cubans and Venezuelans are
often the exam exception to that and we
are talking about Florida so could this
be maybe a path for Suarez to gain some
Traction in the State of Florida
specifically that's number one number
two there is uh I think a good argument
to be made that Suarez is more of a
moderate he has some corruption issues
but on a number of different policy
areas he's a little more of a moderate
sort of like a technocrat has expressed
support for cryptocurrencies and the
like so I'm as curious as anybody else
to see if and how this impacts the race
let's listen to him this morning on Good
Morning America
oh no the clip glitching badly I'm
confident I'm gonna get it fixed for us
though let's take a listen here Good
morning George it's wonderful to be with
you and Good Morning America why are you
running for president
I'm running for president because I
think I have a different message than
what other candidates have I'm
generational and not generational is a
buzzword but as someone who has
implemented generational change to
create prosperity in the city I'm
someone who was a president of the U.S
Conference of Mayor so I know the
problem that 85 percent of Americans who
live in cities and 91 percent who
constitute the GDP of this country are
going through so this is sounding very
focused groupy and not like it I mean
this is not going to appeal to anyone
things like increasing crime
homelessness mental health issues I'm
someone who has a positive track record
of success and has a positive vision for
the future I think what I've noticed in
the last 24 hours just an outpouring of
support because people want someone who
can unify them I was elected by 85
percent and reelected by 80 and as I've
traveled the United States from States
like Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina
Nevada what people want is someone to
bring them together they want to know
more they want to hear hear more about
my track record about what I've
accomplished and what I could do for
them and their children this isn't about
me this isn't about my generation this
isn't about our okay so we'll see if
that message does appeal to anybody the
Miami Herald with an interesting report
and some notes uh about Suarez which
we'll put up on the screen right now for
you
um it says that his brand was recently
tarnished sources told the herald that
Suarez faces scrutiny by the FBI and
local authorities for ten thousand
dollar a month payments he received from
a developer for Consulting work while
serving as mayor which is
extraordinarily Shady that small
potatoes compared to Trump's legal
problems they write but those fees look
like a conflict of interest much as
mounting a long shot yet buzzfilled run
for president in 2020 landed Democrat
Buddha judge a job as U.S Secretary of
Transportation Suarez II might wind up
with a plum political appointment out of
this contest or running another Office
later in other words he could win
without actually winning and lastly
going on to say if he raises enough
money
and gets a couple of viral sound bites
at a presidential debate
Suarez might line up his next job
perhaps as someone's VP or is a paid
political commentator or top political
consultant he's energetic Hispanic
fluent in Spanish appealing to the type
of Voters the Republican party has
invested significant resources to
attract as mayor he's been criticized
for focusing too much on shiny bobbles
and less on the unglamorous job of
leading Miami-Dade County's largest city
but those qualities might play well in
another role so the Miami Herald which
is has followed Suarez very closely says
this is not there not only is there no
chance this is not even really about
running for president this is about
lining himself up for some future role
VP who on Earth knows what will be
interesting to see
is whether Suarez can make it to the
debate stage the RNC just uh under two
weeks ago released its requirements for
making it to the first debate in late
August and I don't have them right in
front of me but they are something along
the lines of a fundraising requirement I
think it's you have to raise money from
at least 40 000 different people
um and you've got to be polling at least
one percent in I believe three different
National polls Suarez can certainly get
himself to one percent and I'm more
interested in what his presence on the
stage could do as a Florida elected
official in contrast to Ron DeSantis you
may have two voices Trump and Suarez
attacking desantis's record at floor as
Florida Governor that would be
interesting it will also be interesting
to see what attacks DeSantis mounts
against Suarez my guess is Trump will
mostly ignore Suarez if they're on the
stage together
um and instead just attack DeSantis so
that will be an interesting dynamic in
the meantime we are going to get a
republican polling update tomorrow but
let's talk about a Chris Christie
appearance on Fox News